so here's where this all leads us to
because you know i don't want to we we
talk a lot about the hypocrisy and stuff
it leads to people finally having enough
we got the stories from the daily mail
50 masterless anti-lockdown protesters
forced their way into la supermarket
after california extends
regional stay-at-home order indefinitely
amid 1 000
spike in hospitalizations they say
police responded to calls about an
unruly crowd
at the arawan market in la's fairfax
district on tuesday afternoon
dozens of massless people were filmed
shoving their way into the store
the protesters berated staffers
demanding that they cover their faces
with
what we just want to shop we don't take
our own precautions that we've been
doing all our lives
and we'll all be fine an organizer of
the demonstration said the incident came
as governor gavin newsom extended state
home order
in the southern california region l.a
county has become one of the nation's
worst hot spots
hot spots in recent weeks
hospitalizations in the country in the
county have grown tenfold in the last
two months so check out this photo
i mean you guys can't see it but for
those that are that are watching you can
it says a crowd of about 50 massless
anti-lockdown protesters
shoving their way into a store you got a
lot of people man i'll tell you i don't
know i don't know if you remember seeing
the videos from earlier in the year of
the stores being shipped clean i mean
first of all toilet paper was the first
to go
i think my favorite video was when
everyone runs full speed and they're
wrestling over toilet paper
it's so weird man like if you're worried
i guess they weren't worried about the
pandemic they're just worried about
wiping their butts
for real all right you know what i'd run
for the food in the bottled water
like if i if i if everyone runs breaks
with toilet paper i'm gonna i'm gonna go
get some produce and some canned goods
i don't know but anyway i digress the
other day we heard a lady
beat a cop with her own baton because
she was told to wear a mask
a navy vet bashed a guy at a bar over
the head with a bottle for being told to
wear a mask
now you've got these people storming
their way into a supermarket saying we
want to shop
so what happens when people start
running out of food
because it's going to happen i mean
people aren't working
california's making the lockdown crazier
you combine that with the hypocrisy
you combine that with people who earlier
in the year were saying one thing and
doing another
and now they've flipped 18 180 and if
you repeat the same thing
the surgeon general said earlier this
year about masks or fauci did
or they'll nuke you they'll get rid of
your account they'll get rid of your
channel
if you say it's xenophobic to ban travel
oh you're gone but they said all of that
when they decide it when when and it's
not even republicans it's
it's mostly democrats when they decide
to say it's fine no matter what it is
they say
that's where we're at right now people
can see that you know you've got
uh murphy in new jersey went out to eat
and got got got harassed by or you got
berated by some people
you've got whitmer went to get her hair
cut you know lori lightfoot
you've got nancy pelosi you got newsome
violating coveted lockdowns
i wonder these people their loved ones
are dying
they can't go out and they can't see
them they can't be in the hospital with
them their children are being born can't
be in the hospital with them either
i've seen tons of comments for people
saying you know my parent or you know
grandparent has been in the hospital
with cancer or some illness and it's
been weeks and they're deteriorating no
one can see them or visit them
and then what do we get the politicians
are breaking their own rules
dr burks on the the task force violates
covid restrictions that she's the advice
she's given goes visits her family
takes photos and then insult to injury
the nurses get on
on camera and choreograph dances and
shuffle about
in a place where people are dying in
mess eventually i think the people are
going to kick the doors into the
supermarket just start taking stuff
and it's probably going to get crazier
than that people are going to start
just this law is going to start breaking
down yeah i mean it already is
well there's a when i'm talking with
somebody and and we're sharing opinions
people can get you know passionate about
it but still you're just met with
an opinion doesn't really go off the
rails when you're talking about it but
when somebody's beliefs are challenged
emotions flare up so i think what's
actually happening is these people are
finally discovering
that you know we held a belief that
we're a country we're a country of
people we're decent we're hard working
we have this american dream story right
and that our our leaders
are really there for us you know in some
way i guess went deep down but but this
is
koba to strip something bare which is
that our leaders don't care at
all about us and probably the most
shocking grotesque display and there
have been many
has to be this most recent stimulus bill
right six
hundred dollars for everybody earning 75
grand or less right
so that you added up that's about 90
billion dollars out of 900 that's 10
going to people right who have been out
of work
for months after months after months
after months so what do you do with 600
bucks after you've been out of work for
you know eight months not a lot right do
you pay your your overdue cable bill or
your cell phone
or what do you do with that right and
then they put
ninety percent of that goes to like
israel and
well one gender 1.3 billion is going to
egypt
700 million is going to sudan 453
million is going
to ukraine and then 500 million is going
to israel
so there so uh to just clarify 200
billion
of the 2.3 trillion omnibus is going to
be disbursed as stimulus payments
the next 700 there's 700 uh
i'm sorry is that 200 billion and then
there's 700 billion that's going to be
dispersed in other
kinds of like uh economic relief like
the paycheck protection program and
things like that
then you get the omnibus spending bill
which was a ton of it is like
general spending programs but a lot of
them are ridiculous like what's the
what's the lizards on on treadmills or
whatever
and the pakistani gender programs i
don't care
what the number is you know we're at a
point where
our economy has been decimated when
we're unable to work and survive
why would you give any money could you
imagine let me just give you an analogy
could you imagine you get fired from
your job right
and you've got a savings of a couple
grand and your rent is like a thousand
bucks a month and you're like well i can
probably last about two months
i'm gonna give my money my neighbor he
seems hungry or you're gonna be like i'm
gonna give away a thousand dollars of my
money for my savings so my neighbor can
take a gender studies class at a local
college
who in their right mind would do that
when they print when they set a 2.3
trillion we're going to get
does that mean that we are going to
borrow 2.3 trillion from the federal
reserve
um it so the run rate of their spend
right now is
is uh run rate on an annualized basis
close to 10 trillion
and total income is around four so
they're spending
not all of that will be borrowed some of
that comes in in in income taxes some of
it comes into social security taxes
fico stuff like that but but by far the
majority of it's being borrowed right
now do you know
what how much of it's being borrowed
about who is it borrowed from how do
they borrow it
well the treasury conducts an auction
and this is a very simple magician trick
right um the federal reserve is not
directly monetizing debt because that
would be banana republic so what happens
is
one of the 23 primary dealers jp morgan
et cetera they go in and they buy these
things and then the federal reserve buys
it from them
and of course they take a little cut you
know they'll skim a couple basis points
to take a little vig
so that's how it works but if you follow
the action the federal reserve is
literally buying fresh
u.s paper the same day in many cases
right so it's
it's just it's just one step to make it
look like it's not what it is which is
the federal reserve prints money out of
thin air and our government spends it
yeah so it sounds like a ponzi scheme
well so what's the long-term effect of
that
the long-term effect is is money is
let's be clear money is just a it's a
it's a social agreement
it's just a it's it's a claim on
something we there's you know that the
the paper in luke's notebook
you know we say is just paper but this
other paper has value or these ones and
zeros on this hard disk mean this but
not that over there
so money is just this thing that we all
agree has value
the long-term effect of just printing
printing printing is you take from
everybody by last time i went to the
grocery store
first time i ever had a 500 grocery bill
right
and i could easily carry the whole thing
right and they tell me
constantly there's no inflation but i
know there is and my health care which i
have to buy as a small business owner
it goes up reliably 10 20 every year
let me tell everybody a trick you can do
right now going to amazon.com
select some electronics put them into
your cart
and then don't buy them close the
browser come back in a week
you'll get a notification happen to me i
was going to buy a tablet
and i forgot opened it up a day or two
later and it said price change 500 to
650.
the cost went up to clarify how we're
borrowing this money so the
the us government will be like we're
going to borrow a trillion from the
federal reserve but what they'll do is
the federal reserve will loan a trillion
to jp morgan or one of 23
banks middlemen and then the bank will
loan it to the u.s government
not not exactly like that um so the
federal the treasury department
puts out let's say a trillion dollars of
treasury bills right three-year notes
five-year notes 10-year notes whatever
they are 30-day bills but they put a
trillion bucks out
and then people bid for them in these
competitive auctions
almost all of that goes to these big
banks the big banks are buying it with
cash they have kicking around most of
which they got from the federal reserve
different mechanism
but that's real cash and then the
federal reserve takes real cash and
wires it into their accounts and takes
those
assets those debt instruments off their
hands so the federal reserve is holding
a bunch of u.s
treasury bills yeah a ton trillions and
we default on that
um not if you have a printing press it's
very hard to do so
so this is this is what what has really
been running and it's going to hit
everybody really hard and i think it's
going to hit us really bad in the next
few years and it's a direct consequence
of all this printing and it's this
the federal reserve my statement about
them is they're what i call a reverse
robin hood organization
they print a lot of money the people who
get their hands on it first do something
called the cantalon effect if you're
closest to it like
if i'm the federal reserve luke you're
sitting there and i print a bunch a
trillion dollars you get it first
because you're the big bank in line
you then spend that on whatever you want
and by the time it trickles out to the
rest of the people stakes are you know
eighteen dollars a pound and whatever
right
because of that what happens is you find
that as a little person your bank
account
it doesn't buy as much anymore your
purchasing power went away
but where'd it go that's the where'd it
go that's the mechanism the mandrake
mechanism the the
sleight of hand so everybody in the
nation all 320 million lose a little bit
of purchasing power from
their bank accounts but it's it's an
economic axiom it had to go
somewhere where did it go if you follow
the story it went to the billionaires
the trillionaires
the the elites they got all of that so
that's why i call the federal reserve
the reverse robin hood because they take
from the many
to give to the few and when you look at
the purchase that makes people pissed
off oh yeah when they realize what's
going on because sadly a lot of people
don't realize what's going on and
they're like yes government
give me my six hundred dollars or my two
thousand dollars immediately and they
think it literally comes out of thin air
it doesn't
you pay for it in one way or another
your children are going to be paying for
it
and if you look at the purchasing power
of the dollar from 10 years ago
20 years ago 30 years ago you will be
absolutely shocked to understand how
fast
the value of the dollar is going down
even just recently as you mentioned in
the supermarket i'm even seeing it and
it's it's uh scary stuff i remember when
i was a kid and a candy bar cost 40
cents
i know dude i used to buy penny candy
yeah that was an alfredo's
yeah i didn't sell it for five cents in
front of my house yeah it worked
and they went up to two cents i remember
that they went from it's one cent to two
cents in like the course of a year and
then they were five cents
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we
go live don't forget to subscribe hit
the like button
hit the notification bell and we are
also available on all podcast platforms
for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time